for most Cameroonians it's just trash
bad for Pierre kamsa loom it's a
valuable resource his plan is to
introduce plastic recycling to Cameroon
on a large scale it is our farm we the
children back in the village we often
sat around the fire and burnt old
plastic bags
have you met I melted and we made balls
from that super a formidable eight but
this is not about toys by adding sand
the molten plastic is mixed into a paste
and pressed into moulds most of the
people working here are youths from
underprivileged families they are
learning a skill that will be greatly
needed in Cameroon producing
cobblestones and slabs this project is
just some few weeks old and there's a
lot that needs to be accomplished por la
mañana para Lac breathing masks I still
have to find them I want them to wear
breathing masks especially when
replacing the filter the project has
been made possible by the man who was
the world's best footballer in the 1990s
world cup casa milà who is now a soccer
ambassador is funding it through his
foundation curled-up leak or heart of
africa motto
let's get to a [ __ ] a me what about 10
minutes a car yeah when you have
finished your football career you have
to find something you can do today I
decided to look for ways to help
Cameroonian youths janessa laginas come
already Mahna has made his cobblestone
workshop his flagship project this
morning he's taking around a friend to
see the work that's been carried out
Josh Saba is a Cameroonian French pop
star visiting the capital yarn de la
Vida saw documentary on television about
it and was very much interested to have
a look I think it's something that
really needs to be supported to be very
mm or four years Pierre comes along
travelled through Africa trying to sell
his idea eventually ha Jamila brought
him back to Cameroon now together with
his girlfriend he's looking for a house
at the moment
he lives with one of Miller's employees
don't be near that worried for coming I
think it's time I took full
responsibility for my life and have a
family
responsibly complex our digger pulling
this the next step is that we would like
to get married
Sumalee a PS project promises more
stability in his life he wants to build
dozens of such workshops across Cameroon
eventually he hopes his idea will be
used in all of Yan days walkways
you